you see the trouble I mean I go to Gaza
right not as often as I would like and
it's probably a discussion you know we
should have in there as a political
discussion I mean the problem with Gaza
is not really a problem of humanitarian
desire to help because actually we have
a huge desire to help in a humanitarian
sense and I was actually responsible for
changing the Israeli policy on Gaza
after the flotilla incident and so on
and we're working hard to change it even
further but it is a political problem
I'm afraid now you can resolve that
political problem and I hope in
Palestinian politics it is resolved and
you can say instantly and it's a totally
different thing
I completely condemn Israeli policy if
you want to say that you can say that
but it's it's not a case of faiths
ignoring the humanitarian plight because
actually people want to help the
humanitarian situation there but the
politics is very complicating so I think
you know there are times when when faith
will give us an answer and there are
times when I'm afraid there is a
political issue that has to be resolved
before faith can really give us an
answer and I hope and believe that we
can get a peace deal going in the Middle
East and I'm very happy that another
time to talk to you all about the Middle
East peace process and how it works and
you know what what I think about it but
you know we've got to be clear that you
can give a certain amount of
responsibility to Israeli policy for
Gaza but you can't ignore Hamas and what
they do also in Gaza which is not good
right and when we launched the peace
talks with President Obama at the White
House and Hamas then killed some
settlers right on the day of it you know
that's not good
I mean it's wrong
it's done to disrupt the process it then
makes it a lot harder for people like me
to argue with the Israelis we should
open up Gaza to the world so you know
there is politics in this but every you
and I maybe have that discussion at
length